كتفت حكومه طالبان الانتشار الامنيه امام
الجامعات الافغانيه لمنع دخول الفتيات كما
قامت باخراج الفتيات من السكن الجامعي
بجامعه كابول بالقوه بعد فصل الكهرباء
وقال مراسل العربيه ان عدد من اساتذه
الجامعات الافغانيه استقالوا بسبب حظر
تعليم الفتيات في الوقت نفسه اعلنت منظمه
التعاون الاسلاميه انها حذرت حكومه طالبان
من اتخاذ قرارات تعسفيه ضد المراه في
افغانستان معبره عن استنكارها عبر تعليم
الفتيات هذا وقالت المبعوثه الامريكيه
لشؤون المراه في افغانستان
متطرفه ومرفوضه كما اكد المبعوث الامريكي
الى افغانستان توم ويستمع عرضه بلاده
سياسات حظر تعليم الفتيات باقوى العبارات
واستمرار في الادانه دانه المانيا من على
الفتيات من التعليم في افغانستان متهمه
حكومه طالبان بتدمير مستقبل هذا البلد
بحضر التعليم الجامعي على النساء واشارت
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لينا بير
بوك الى ان طالبان ربما تحاول جعل النساء
غير مرئيات لكن لن تنجح مضيفه ان العالم
يراقب واعلنت بيربوك انها قررت طرحه
المساله على جدول اعمال مجموعه السبع التي
تتولى المانيا حاليا الرئاسه الدوله
من العاصمه الافغانيه كابول تنضم الينا
ناشطه في حقوق المراه والتعليم سدابا
بياني مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض كيف تنظرين وتعلقين كمراه افغانيه
على حضر تعليم الفتيات الجامعي من قبل
طالبات
جدا
[موسيقى]
مع صديقه همم
يوم امس عندما سمعت بهذا الخبر
وفي البدايه اردت ان اتاكد من صحه الخبر
وللاسف عندما سمعت انه صحيح
تفاجئت بذلك
كنا نتوقع في الحقيقه ان يتم المنع ولكن
ليس الى هذا الحد
وخاصه الان فتره الامتحانات مع نهايه
العام قناه عشان بقول لها اي رقم يا كبير
حتى بتقديم امتحاناتهم في مختلف الجامعات
لذلك انا شخصيا تاثرت بشكل كبير مثل سائر
النساء الافغانيات
وللاسف السلطات لا تسمع لصوتي احد ولما
طالبه يعني هناك فتيات اخرجنا من السكن
الجامع في احد جامعه كابول بالقوه تم فصل
الكهرباء ايضا اخرجوا بشكل تعسفي هل
تواصلت مع احد هل نقلت اليك اي قصص من قصص
قصص هؤلاء الطالبات
قسمه كده
في الجامعات الحكوميه
وفي ظل اغلاق الجامعات الحكوميه لجات
الكثير من الفتيات الى جامعات الخاصه الان
الحظر وصل الى هذه الجامعات ايضا
فقلت اما يجيء همم
[موسيقى]
اللواتي ياتينا من مختلف الاقاليم ليس
لديهن اي سوا هذه
الاماكن التي يلقون فيها والان حائرات لا
يعرفنا ماذا يفعل طبعا نشير الى هذا
العاجل السعوديه تقول بانها تستغرب وتاسف
لقرار حكومه التصريف الاعمال الافغانيه
منع الفتيات من التعليم الجامعي اذا همم
السعوديه تعلق على قرار منع حركه همم
طالبان الفتيات همم الافغانيات من التعليم
الجامعي بانها تستغرب وتاسف لقرار حكومه
تصريف الاعمال الافغانيه منعرف فتيات من
التعليم الجامعي سيده سوداء عود اليك مره
اخرى لاساله هنا عن
كميه وحجم الاذنات الواسعه على المستوى
الدولي على مستوى المنظمات منظمات التعاون
الاسلامي الامم المتحده وغيرها اييي هل هي
قادره على الضغط على اا يعني طالبان بان
تتراجع عن هذا القرار او على الاقل ان
تحدد مده زمنيه لانها قالت بانه همم لوقت
غير معلومه وحتى اشعر اخر
مزيكا
قرار المملكه العربيه السعوديه بهذه
الادانه واطالب باقي الدول الاسلاميه
والدول العالم ان تتخذ نفس الموقف
لانه همم
البلد يحتاج الى وقفه النساء افغانستان
ليست بمعزل عن باقي دول العالم الاسلامي
التي يسمح بها التعليم للفتيات فلماذا يتم
منع البنات والفتيات همم والنساء
الافغانيات نحن نطالب بالمزيد من الضغط
على السلطات
والوقوف مع هؤلاء النساء اللواتي يطالب
انه يتم اسكان اصواتهن لكنهن مستمرات في
المطالبه بحقوقهم الاساسيه والمشروعه
اخوكم شريف
حقوق الانسان وحقوق النساء كافه الشرائع
الدينيه والقوانين الدوليه لكن طالبان
تضرب عرض الحائط طيب سواء بوعودها او بهذه
القوانين او بالاعتراف بحق المراه
بالوصول الى حقوقها
الاساسيه لذا نحن بحاجه الى وقفه دوليه
ان النساء تتمكن من
العوده الى مقاعد همم الدراسه
وسائر الممارسات همم
اريد هنا ان ان اسال هل تشعر المراه
الافغانيه بانها خذلت خذلت هنا تحدث عن
الولايات المتحده التي كانت قد بعثت
بتطميات فيما يخص وضع المراه الافغانيه من
قبل راس الاداره الامريكيه رئيس بعد
الانسحاب من افغانستان العام الماضي
اسمك مؤمن
من قبل المجتمع الدولي على حكم طالبان ما
نراه في الواقع ان الظلم لا يزال مستمرا
البنات لا يستطيعن الذهاب الى المدارس
اي احترام لحقوق النساء في افغانستان حتى
من يرفعنا اصواتهن وقمنا بالاحتجاج يتم
اعتقالهن والمجتمع الدول اللي صامت للاسف
لم نسمعيه همم
نشره الرابعه من العاصمه الافريقانيه
كابول ناشطه في حقوق المراه والتعلم
السداب همم يعني همم الانسه نتابع هذا
الفيديو
استاذ جامعي في افغانستان همم سمح همم
للطالبات بدخول القاعات في الجامعه كما
نشاهد هذا الفيديو اذا احد الاساتذه في
احد الجامعات افغانستان سمحا للطالبات
بدخول الفصول الجامعيه رغم القرار الذي
اعلنته يوم امس
حكومه طالبان بمنع الفتيات وحضرهن من
التعليم الجامعي
[موسيقى]